[Música]
oh Lola listos para distribuidora de historia
cuando Joanne caca a con incansable
tecnología diaria blockchain a porky is the
technology is I'll reverse the todo que
hemos consider on days when the presento
make on us and con me name discreto or
a blockchain Savano  acaba de casarse en
pasaporte pero tengo una pieza las
tarifas de BNC serán una O con un coro o una polca
el marketing solo así que busqué hora de
negocios y alineé la cadena de bloques de la calle
este es uno de esos proyectores que que
j'ai vu tan en bahador en  the blockchain
name for ahem blow me an emmy contact
the seeker infrequent are simplemente
blockchain Kim
escucha the blockchain algunos yo creo
que no me voy a cubic are C digo que la
miseria kondou-san blockchain for
Bitcoin la famosa crypto moneda kill you
pasado Jaguar co  -star kasi 20 mil
dólares pero lo importante es la
tecnología que está atrás de este
registro de juego de viuda complejo pero yo
inventé una explicación propia muy fácil él
hace pasar este sofá r lo van a poder
explica la cadena de rock
hasta la Vella Auto euros Thomas Thomas
nos hace protagonistas
Pepe cuando ella consiguió el memorial masculino tú
nacho Chico con malicia intenciones
imaginando la forma licia PG&E memoria masculina
entonces él se quedó a notre todo en una
Hinda él agarró la en de ya know
tow-  linen you know comp reppin Linea dos
gemelos Papas tres cuatro etc.
so anti so después el Chacal
again the eat Moya
Kayla's torpe esto is
kamekona Simoes registro commune
centralized only broken table kimono
India pasta la siguiente Pepe discoteca
nacho see La Vie opressed Ando cien
pesos oh no Pepe D CK seen a [ __ ]
tsukino
pero Pepe el momento  no tienes la gente
entonces no el apoyo mostrar nacho no
quiero volver cien pesos
entonces que hace en la noche e  l entrada
Casa
encuentra la gente encuentra la linea
siento banco a rastro no Borah amarillo
cambia pobre Sally Kohn Daniela entonces
levanta Pepe mira la gente salir con
Gabriella's alekan Daniela nulliparous
una der ro
a school bus a nacho pasa el tiempo
no elige con tu aparición en  llamado
problema entonces el confess up epic a
live earful cific Adela not a pelipper
Dona well gcd inventor una manera de
prata her sedated nachos convalecent
rin Sione's para el futuro e la venta
loc ah a cave a musky M problema de
registro commune centralize da  de Alta
vulnerable a dot parent attack
external no Peppa piensa invented a
second Ln control programa de
cryptography ax k agora any text o
lo procesador yellow transformer
hush-hush
Asuna secuencia the Trinity dos in Volos
minúscula Ozma you school o sinew in
qualcare organ-y  pass una cosa muy
interesante pobre ejemplos chip procesador
por este programa y la palabra Ola
Sal a este 'has pero si procesador la
palabra Ola consiglio Dexter imagine Sal
a total mentos Trojan us que
change simbolo new meruna let say kamba poor
completo IPE Pentimento blockchain la
famosa cardinal de blacas Siegen de por
favor our acogedor complejo Pepe
deciduous la siguiente cuando Ella no de algo a
sua gente esta nota
Ella Campania con una hush
see introdujo aquí el programa la linea
mass el Hadj interior a él
vamos a tomar Quattro know para ser lo
más rápido por country into those homes
azumarill pepe hey Neera premiere hush
kisses yamaha genesis cero cero señor señor
el espacio la nota  comp reppin
Ehlo propiedad de la compañía hush cover en ninguna
certeza de kiss hush anti or cero cero
cero cero mas la linea comp reppin lo
repeat Oh Linea dos y la nota gemelos
pappy square in the DOS Trinity cuatro
kiss hash declarando sin certeza Oh
Cho áspero  interior mess gemelos Papa's
ie aparecer la famosa Kadena no jelly
square Oh preguntar kiva pasar con cada
nota he camber por lo menos una lettera
Claro  say welcome bar el Hadj desta nota
is a Campbell hush Savannah camber todos
los coches que sigue por esto dicen que
blockchain is indeleble in mo table
party second bar own solo pixel and
qualcare Notice a se vuelven estériles calla
todas esas pérdidas kiss Egon Tinian de una
cosa parecer supresor muchas cosas scope other
for am flow phimosis crypto
monitors bitcoin inventor Satoshi nakamoto's
Miller shot
el dijo la siguiente vamos a crear una
larga cadena de blacas Don de cada block
Kanchana
vinkle O'Connell hush the black interior
los nuevos datos y resolution de  una
tarea matemática compleja
y para que circular alguna platen el
sistema de space decade hablo que vamos
a distribuidor
una cantidad de crypto Moniz entry toda
la gente que decía Alma cenar a
certificate estos datos y guar Darla's
en sus computadoras cada persona en
cualquier momento puede ver  estado de
blockchain esto nos da transparencia por
que como no I UN Centro que se puede
thakkar todas las
cortes  the computer door and lurid guarda
todo block chamber completo entonces
cada persona en cualquier momento puede
ver estado de la red
cuantos bitcoins en cada cuenta pero por
otro lado los dedos estan perdidos
porque esta canción como hash no
commercio entonces transparencia absoluta
e para la distancia ocurre  en blockchain
cuando nuestro horno estaba a pasar por kiss and
reverse that of the camos Cunha sido la
confianza que pasa con confianza
nosotros los hermanos lamentablemente no
podemos confiar en Tracy no por que somos
mijito soma las personas she no porque
la vida span complejo que no  sabemos que
no swap as her siguiente momento por
ejemplo
yo p de plata prasada de spaceman Fermo
entonces por más que la quiero de volver
no puedo
yes tora comment' a para proteger los
acuerdo Sentra personas tenemos mucho
center mid abogado scribe a know
estado banco policia  esto aqui otra clave
mismo coche Gandhi certificado calcetin raros
e7 muna fiesta como comision dum en
blockcha  in cumbia most la confianza
Hagar entry personas intermediarios por
lo que sigue con sensor sensor consenso
on las reglas de Lorette protégée dos
con creeped agraphia Kippur mas que una
tienda de ser on peddlers no puede and
throws his blockchain its own internal
don't de las  personas no second awesome
no confit an entry see pero Sigyn Boyden
seguir trabajando juntos por que es su
sack raros pobres ot hella criptografía
a blockchain por si por esta cosa
ejemplos por ejemplo blockchain
Valkenburg pobre completo lo que tiene personales
que ver con
identidad atados ejemplos un
estudiante que pasar de una universidad
de como poseído ahora tiene que
Sivaraman Tunde
ple certificado los una papel CPR papá
especialmente sistema no funciona NOSSA de
Moura tiempo y también los  papers upon
perder Seaguar dar diploma de una
estudiante blockchain él puede ver
sol  amente silencio un cálculo que del mundo
Universidad asesino ECB muy pocos Candela
cadena de blacas
Saavik es un estudiante de diploma no ii una
sola lettre noona solo no de otro
ejemplo qué matrimonio implosionó Sybilla
papá que tiene la mayor complejidad en el nombre
Soy dueño de él  golpe muy lindo viajó en
el segmentado am activista sin complexión
el nombre en su poema apanasana su
lanham Chiquita y pasando problema I
muchos animales salvajes esos animales
asumir problema a la gente entonces en
pasar Ella estudio permiso yugo una estrella
estos anómalos incluso hay el núcleo
restaurantes lo que pase de restaurante
a no quiero comprar cuarto
porque no sabes donde probablemente cualquier
lugar agudo Oh si la guarda en BNC temperatura
estado como como de Visser en dosis que
hacen cuando casa mediodía
animal see you so come in a restaurant a
la mesa de la persona todo esto segments
of the garden blockchain entonces el
momento the receiver esta carn  e can lo
receive puede ver todo todo todo el
cielo mental case in what a blinken
family income balbuceo y blockchain en
blockchain tenemos lo que si chiama
contrato sinful agendas smart contracts
is contra de la gente some contrato que
si esta nose-kiss x skeleton papeles
no Eskimo Kosovo no es un
comentario completamente automatizado un ejemplo
reducción unas critter man de una nota
as widget or el momento que lo mando
automatic Ament a ocio gap ago in
crypto monitors entonces no manera de no
trabajo no a manera de no pagar por el
trabajo  esto nos Valluvar a lo que se
llama economía programable a porque
como puede ella papá de acuerdo aterrador que
van a hacer cumplir dos de ba o significo
nuestro vamos a polen si un auto / supuesto
con más fe CN co y lo que más importante
me parece  personalmente blockchain bien
compare lo que veo en e elecciones en mi
en Stacey Gwadar votos de cada persona
knock chain en guna manera de física
moon so Lovato porque si como este vato
Savannah comp  are todos los votos kiss
Eagan esto NOS de transparencia absoluta
and
choice estos ejemplos s and negocios de la vida
kochujang parami lo mas importante que
me parece cambio que blockchain Wow
initiating la conciencia de las personas
por que a coma and blockchain no tenemos
intermediarios no tenemos  una tercera
can que her sake and Eric Lamar vamos a
tener otros Vallauris when Ella tragar
rescate práctica Austin blockchain is El
concierne so automatización de confianza
it's low-key estaba hablando chip or
muskie persona quiere romper la regla no
puede hacerlo porque esta protegida
dokkan cryptography  in blockchain
practicum o--'s intercambio a respeto
Muto s decir que cada persona que hacer
algo para la red Vassar a company porque
si por mucho tiempo circus gratis
apareció alguna motivación entonces que VA
a pasar el la mano cuando no tiene UN
Tercero a  kendrick lamar vaster mucho
mas consciente
mucho mas responsable a con su propia
vida y quiero cantar event es  to NOS ha a
g VAR estado de comunidad adolescencia a
una comunidad mas adulterer mas
responsable a mess consciente con sus
propias vidas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]